quand j'étais à l'école primaire
un enfant un peu plus avec moi et qui me
prenaient pour responsable d'absolument
tous les maux du monde cherchait souvent
me frapper à m'humilier à m'étrangler
dans ces moments là j'étais tétanisée
complètement immobile et j'ai appelé à
l'aide désespérément mais les mots ne
voulais même plus franchir mes lèvres et
à une vingtaine de mètres seulement mes
instituteurs et mes camarades jouer
tranquillement des coups des insultes à
répétition
j'en ai subi jusqu'à ce que je finisse
le collège puis c'est en parlant avec
des proches des amis des camarades que
je me suis rendu compte que le
harcèlement touché énormément personnes
et que même si nous y sommes tous
confrontés nous laissons tous faire
quand je dis tous c'est à la fois celui
qui harcelait celui qui harcèlent bien
sûr mais aussi celui qui est spectateur
et qui ne bouge pas j'aimerais aussi
vous montrer combien il est facile de
passer d'une catégorie à l'autre et
qu'elles ne sont pas si distinctes que
ça la première catégorie
la première perspective est celle du
harceler de la victime
même si je suis sur scène et que j'en
parle ouvertement certains d'entre vous
comme moi ont pu grandement souffrir des
effets du harcèlement en tant que parent
seul et nous avons tous tendance à
laisser faire
étonnamment c'est même le premier
conseil qu'on nous donne laisse donc
faire ça leur passera
c'est pourtant pour moi une grossière
erreur que de laisser faire
chaque insulte qu'on le montre ou non
peut nous blesser aucun d'entre nous
n'est infaillible ou insensible
peu importe ce qu'il prétend on me l'a
beaucoup dit de laisser faire le
personnel enseignant n'avait en général
que ce mot là à la bouche pensons que le
harcèlement c'est serait alors je
laissais l'air se leurrent m'insulter se
moquer m'isoler
puisque un jour forcément il arrêterait
mais il continué évidemment et au fond
de moi même
même si je ne voulais vraiment pas le
montrer chaque geste de mépris me
faisait encore plus mal que le précédent
laissez faire impliquer aussi de rester
muet sur ma tristesse sans aide et sans
soutien
nous nous replions sur nous mêmes nous
isolons de tous que ce soit de noirceux
les mais surtout de notre entourage se
laisser être harcelées et la pire des
erreurs possibles car nous intériorise
ont toutes les insultes que nous
recevons plein porte notre âge surtout
si elles sont répéter tous les jours on
laissons s'installer le harcèlement dans
sa routine nous banalisons notre propre
calvaire et peu à peu nous détruisons
notre cerveau est telle qu à force
d'écouter et d'absorber tout ceci une
question vicieuse viendra forcément nous
torturer et s'il avait raison quand
cette question est apparu dans mon
esprit le harcèlement est devenue une
vraie torture mentale
je ne croyais plus en moi même je ne
pouvais plus de joie et les étudier à
quoi bon si l'on insulté et que je
devais laisser faire en laissons
s'installer le harcèlement dans sa
routine nous banalisons notre propre
calvaire et ainsi nous détruisons
lorsque j'ai laissé le harcèlement faire
j'ai entamé ma descente aux enfers cette
politique du laisser-faire a tellement
plus détruits dans ma vie qu'elle a pu
aider tout premièrement j'ai aimé
harceleur puis progressivement l'école
ma haine se tournant vers le lieu et le
système qui me poussait à l'essai en
l'air puis pour finir c'est ma propre
personne que gm ne laissons jamais les
harceleurs faire parlons-en à nos
proches à notre entourage à ceux qui
peuvent nous aider mais nous nous
résignons jamais à laisse faire après
avoir parlé du harceler parlons
maintenant du harceleur
même si ces mots sont tantôt nîmes ils
peuvent cependant se rejoindre une fois
appliqué à une personne je ne parlerai
pas ici du pur sadisme car il n'est pas
dans la majorité des cas la vraie raison
du harcèlement
je vois deux raisons principales qui
peuvent nous faire tomber facilement
dans le harcèlement tout d'abord
harceler peut être un mécanisme de
défense
si on est soi même harcelés nous pouvons
ainsi blessé quelqu'un afin de nous
sentir mieux vis à vis de notre propre
harcèlement ou pour nous rassurer
vis-à-vis de notre manque de confiance
en soi
à partir de ce moment le harcèlement
prends comme une forme de thérapie ou
détruire l'autre semble nous
reconstruire un peu quand j'étais
harcelé les harceler moi aussi et je ne
connais personne qui a autant souffert
des conséquences de mon propre
harcèlement que mon propre frère j'étais
immensément jaloux de lui de sa
popularité mais surtout du fait que lui
n'était pas harcelés alors je lui en
voulais et la victime devenait bourreau
ainsi on se laisse faire soi-même à
reproduire les actes qui nous ont
pourtant fait mal vous voyez le fossé
entre harcelés et harceleurs n'est pas
si grand ont harcelé va justifier ces
moqueries en se disant que lui a subi
bien pire qu'on ait conscience ou non du
harcèlement que l'on reproduit nous
sommes harceleur tout de même et à
chaque réflexion narquoise que nous
faisons à quelqu'un nous pouvons le
heurter indépendamment de ce que nous
avons souffert par le passé pour moi je
me disais que je ne faisais pas de mal à
mon frère
j'avais connu tellement pire en se
laissant faire on peut devenir un
bourreau inconscient
en étant pourtant une victime consciente
la seconde raison qui peut nous faire
devenir très facilement harceleur et le
harcèlement en groupe on harcèle en
groupe afin de se sentir intégré au
groupe
l on se dégage ainsi de toute la
responsabilité puisque la faute revient
au groupe
peu importe qu'on soit en groupe ou non
qu'on ait subi le harcèlement non ou
qu'on en ait conscience
ce collègue à qui je fais des remarques
perpétuelle peut-être l'at-il mal pris
peut-être on souffre utile beaucoup sans
le montrer
peut-être suis-je moi aussi ce que je
n'aurais jamais cru être un harceleur le
laisser-faire n'est pas uniquement le
privilège du harcelé et du harceleur
mais il est hélas trop souvent liée à
l'absence de réaction des spectateurs du
harcèlement le harcèlement ne se déroule
généralement pas dans une petite ruelle
isolé alors qu'il fait nuit
mais il a lieu en plein jour en public
que ce soit à l'école sur le lieu de
travail ou dans les transports en commun
le harcèlement se déroule alors qu'il y
a généralement beaucoup de personnes
dans mon cas c'était toute une cour de
récréation qui était témoin de ce que je
vivais en sont ils responsables pour
autant il ne me frappait pas il ne me
plaît pas mais pourtant c'était leur
rôle d'agir tout comme il est le nôtre
dans des situations analogues en étant
spectateurs nous avons la possibilité de
mettre un terme à des actions qui
peuvent détruire une personne
pourtant dans la plupart des cas nous
n'agissons pas pourquoi la peur
la peur est une des raisons majeures
pour ne pas agir peur du ou des
harceleurs qui va nous pousser à ne pas
arrêter ce qui peut se passer devant
nous alors nous devrions arrêter ce qui
se passe puisque le harcèlement a des
conséquences inimaginables au niveau
psychique
j'ai moi même conscience de ce qu'il
engendre
et pourtant même moi j'ai pu laisser
faire toujours pas par sadisme mais
uniquement par peur d'être une nouvelle
fois stigmatisé comme à part celui qui
va aider un autre alors que la foule
reste muette et ignorent dans ce cas la
peur ne vient pas du harceleur mais tout
simplement des autres qui nous entoure
et puis s'il n'enterrons pas cette scène
quelqu'un son chargeur ah non c'est
possible tout comme il se peut que
personne n'intervienne
et alors nous aussi qui passons à côté
avant une part de responsabilité dans la
descente aux enfers du harcelé nous
mettions à la place du harcelé que se
passerait-il
imaginons comment nous verrions les
choses du point de vue de celui qui
subit
je suis certain que vous avez déjà tous
une fois ressenti la sensation d'être
harcelés alors ne laissez pas un autre
le subir sept autres ce pourrait être
vous ce pourrait être vos enfants vos
frères et vos soeurs vos amis sept
autres c'est un être humain que pourtant
vous laisser se détruire peu à peu
devant vos yeux
alors et si nous arrêtions laisser faire
le harcèlement je vous remercie